do you ever do that thing where like you
record a song and then play it through a
tiny speaker so like you'd be hearing it
on your car radio we used to we used to
have an what they call an AA tone but we
haven't done that we used to have a
pirate radio station that was hooked up
to our studio so then we would play it
through to just hear what it sound like
the radio compression and what it
sounded like the Pirate Radio Station
didn't go to anybody did it or did it go
through like the town or the community
it went it ended up in an FCC van yeah
us
oh that's badass yeah we ended up if we
like and then we accidentally uh caused
the blackout in like in Los FES you guys
are nuts yeah you're not allowed to do
that because people who buy a radio
station you're overpowering their
station and neighbor had a cordless
phone and he's he's he like all I hear
on my cordless phone is is your radio
station man can you like not we came
back and the FCC had put a card on the
yeah that on the door yeah we came cuz
it was on uh my rooftop of where we were
staying we were recording 21st Century
Breakdown all of a sudden I looked down
and there was like an FCC card that was
right there they knew exactly where it
was coming from and what were they
saying like hey dudes you better shut
down this radio station we're going to
[__] come after you and find you
right they eventually came back and
wanted to see everything but our guys
had actually locked it all up in a
trailer and then um they couldn't they
couldn't unlock the trailer without a
without a yeah it it was like that when
the go The Godfather when they send the
horse head inside the guy's
bed were you scared at
all but but did you you know what I mean
you're breaking the law I mean it's it's
you weren't scared it just like hey [__]
this I'm going to do it no we weren't we
didn't really scared we just took it
down you know we they they they they
were on to us so we took it down
but yeah we still have the equipment how
cool for the neighborhood though like
hey Green Day set up a little uh radio
station just for our our area no we used
to do it down in like Newport Beach uh
in Orange County and um we set it up
pretty powerful and like like so all of
like the surf shops and the Surfers
would you know we would play like the
blues and punk rock and stuff so they
would and it was on 247 so we'd have
like playlists that would kept
going